speaking of things dying
Starcraft 2 basically got killed
are you still playing that [__] uh yeah
I built a new computer oh did you really
yeah yeah and what's the I mean what are
the specs
um fast as [__] really I don't even
really know
what I don't I don't know you don't know
what the specs are I didn't like look at
this did someone else build it for you
no no I just told Siva what do I buy buy
me all the best [__]
um I know I definitely panel on his
stinky money but you know what I'm
saying like you were like so tell me
what to buy and I'll buy it yeah yeah
yeah yeah so but you built it yeah nice
yes but in your garage no it's right
there on the dinner table nice
I bet your wife loved that yep yep I was
done in about four hours really it's in
and out pretty good yeah I was watching
the UFC fight okay having a time I
bought these parts
like three months ago
no not three I bought them over like
near Christmas and I just built it now
sheesh yeah this is sick
this is super sick
thanks Ted yeah that's a sexy ass box
right there yep I love your box thanks
dude yeah yeah I thought it was pretty
clean box yeah definitely shaved you
know I I thought I was because my PC's
been making some weird s sounds too and
I'm like how old is this now I'm
thinking about it it's been a minute
like we were recording the first that's
cringe on that [__] computer oh so
it's got to be five years old more than
that and Morse yes that's crazy I know
right it feels like that's weird it
feels like just yesterday that four USB
strips with like 10 USB plugs oh dude
you you just that's what you have to do
right how else are you supposed to get
what though yeah but like oh there's
solutions for that now
what are the solutions for it uh like I
have a lot of [__] I have to plug into
the PC yeah you got a lot of tripods a
lot of cameras in there too the razor
yeah all my cameras
where am I gonna plug those in
uh this is for power
plugging your tripods in
yeah the tripods they have to recharge
no the guy the the tripod store said
they have to plug this Cable in he sold
me the cable
the tripod cable is like a thousand
dollars each yeah it's uh it's what's
the [__] branded cable that you used
to get like Radio Shack that was so
expensive monster yeah
everyone from Best Buy would get fired
because they would sell those in the
parking lot
really oh yeah what do you mean sell
them in the parking lot that was like a
thing at Best Buy where some Bozo
customer would walk in and be like I
want the monster games with like 300
Dallas and then the best my employee
would go meet me on my lunch no way yeah
so they would steal them from no we
because we would get them
for for like two bucks yeah we give them
like twenty dollars
um Best Buy actually changed their
policy I heard so that they only give
employees a 10 discount across because
we used to get everything you used to
get everything at Cost okay what was the
cost of those things uh 20 bucks and
they sell them for 300.
dude that is on I'm I'm right now I'm
listening to like a podcast about just
the history of like Louis Vuitton and
Christian Dior and stuff like that and
how it's like essentially the best
business in the world because the
margins are higher than any anything
else but that is the only thing
Monster Cables are the only business
that's better than the different clothes
oh bro Best Buy did this horrendous
thing where uh this was right when
Amazon was really picking up and big box
retailers were just starting to like go
out of business they're changing all
their inventory
and the first thing that everyone went
for were peripherals so
every big box retailer
took away cheap printer cables and then
they Best Buy especially they they made
their own Dynex was the brand or
whatever
and they would the cost on them was a
dollar nineteen and they'd sell them for
fifty dollars
and they would stock them right next to
the printers
and so people who had come in they'd buy
a printer for 100 bucks and they like I
need to use this today
you have to pay that extra 50 bucks what
is it about cables because I've bought
Monster Cables for some reason it's like
like what is it about cables that tricks
your brain into thinking oh this there
is a premium version of this
I mean I think and not all the other
[__] I think in music maybe that's that
actually applies but outside of that
yeah I don't know maybe the material
yeah but yeah I remember people would be
so livid or like you get these guys out
of running that came from the old world
[__] cables were cheap yeah and they
just walk in and say hey I got an old
printer I'm trying to hook up I need a
USB like you could tell her from the old
world because they they knew the type
yeah like I need a USB a to be I go
I think a 45 [__] are you [__]
kidding and they'd give me a speech
about and you would say leave me on my
lunch break no I never did that yeah I
watched so many people get fired I'm
like I'm good yeah but yeah Monster
Cables man
that's um see you got you guys can get
the um gold-plated edition of this
podcast
for 300 a month we record the exact same
episode line by line super durable yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
no no we just record everything on
Monster Cables now you know what we
should yeah that it's that yeah but you
know we should do is like edit in like
like static and [__] like into the
episode like cuts out every now and then
we're like ah it's the because because
you're on the free gear get the Monster
uh audio Edition yeah if you go to TMG
Studios it's uh trust me it's we record
everything on Monsters
yeah so I said line by line yes we cover
it off yeah yeah the original episode
the free one that's plugged into my
computer at home yeah I need to build a
new a new PC or no I need to ditch my PC
I don't [__] need it anymore I just
use every my Mac does everything I need
yeah you should try it out man yeah I
built the PC oh well Starcraft is I'm
not playing as much I like playing but
I've hit the skill cap where
I'd have to like really have like
defined like play style and build order
and
yeah I don't know yeah I just want to
have fun yeah but there was a major turn
I mean Starcraft 2 has been on its last
leg for a minute but
um
the I guess like Inc there's like a big
tournament in Korea and they announced
what the prize pool would be this year
and a lot of like the Starcraft
streamers kind of broke it down they're
like
if you won all of these you might you
might make a hundred grand okay that's
just one person could make 100 Grand so
it's like not worth it yeah everyone's
probably about to it's probably just
about to be a game yeah that people play
like a weekly
tournament uh shout out to the ESL
they're still keeping it somewhat alive
but yeah
you know you play Hogwarts Legacy
um no I actually did pick up Eldon ring
though okay that game's awesome
is it new
I mean not no like is there a new one
they actually I think they just rolled
out some DLC but the lore the art for a
game it's [__] it is [__] up how it
like expensive that game is and
when you're playing it the atmosphere is
Bar None that [__] I feel you know I
slept on it for so long but
that uh this is it you just look at this
picture
that's the game you look at this picture
for 80 hours yeah and you just imagine
you as him and you're like sick
nah it's uh
I'm not even I've just scratched the
surface of the game but playing it
the like the visual perception of
everything is crazy
what are you gonna do on your new PC
what can you do on it like anything like
does it have the best graphics card yeah
I mean I pretty much have like pretty
much best everything I was playing
OverWatch
I haven't played that game in years I
download OverWatch too destroying kids
really yeah nice
[__] yeah going like 30 like my Katie is
like 30 and six like just wrecking [__]
granted I'm probably like down in like
bronze like my ranking is super low but
I'm just laughing
like this this really is this is Peak
classism right here yeah just frying
kids it was like graphics cards are at
like 400 degrees Celsius they're like
[__] I'm dropping frames I'm like I'm
mining crypto right now at the same time
and training an AI model actually were
you overwhelmed by all like the the
Sprites and everything
why don't you go ahead and respawn think
about that